Elena con la ayuda de su hijo misa se
afanan el limpiarlo sus compras del
tejado para poder aislarlo con plásticos
antes de que llegue el frío su casa como
la mayoría de las casas residenciales de
su barrio ha sido destruida por los
bombardeos olen está preocupada por las
limitaciones del gas y los cortes de
electricidad en los próximos meses
va a ser muy duro el precio del gas es
muy caro y no sé cómo vamos a poder
pagarlo Así que estoy reutilizando los
muebles y ventanas para usarlos como
leña
Esta es la escuela donde estudiaba misa
recibe el impacto de una explosión y se
rompieron las ventanas el colegio
arrabión septiembre predictor ha tenido
que mandar a los alumnos a estudiar
online porque las aulas no están
acondicionadas para el invierno
Estamos buscando fondos para reponer las
ventanas nuestros alumnos estudian
online porque no podemos dar clases así
necesitamos reparar la escuela para que
podamos regresar a las aulas
la reconstrucción es uno de los
principales desafíos de cara este
invierno al que se enfrentan miles de
familias ucranianas que viven en hogares
en males condiciones para soportar Las
bajas temperaturas
esto es todo lo que queda de la vivienda
de Tatiana y su hija Verónica un
bombardeo aéreo destruyó su casa y otras
muchas de este barrio al norte Charly
Hills
no sabemos qué hacer no queremos
marcharnos queremos empezar a
reconstruir nuestra vivienda pero no
tenemos suficiente dinero
Tatiana es una de las pocas afortunadas
que han contado refugio para el próximo
invierno vive en un alejamiento para
desplazados internos que cuenta con el
apoyo de unicef y otras organizaciones
humanitarias
ha llegado el frío y hemos empezado
nuestro programa para la preparación del
Invierno significa que necesitaremos más
generadores para calefacciones
calentadores y otros aparatos eléctricos
van a llegar más desplazados mucha gente
está viviendo en casas bombardeadas que
no van a ser funcionales en invierno
después de ocho meses de guerra cerca de
800.000 hogares Siguen sin electricidad
Tatiana y Elena así como miles de
familias ucranianas han decidido
quedarse y enfrentar un invierno que
será más duro de lo normal